hello rejects Greg here and yes yes I
literally poke you in the face yeah
we're gonna watch the shredder for a Tom
Hanks Emma Watson movie closed circle
I've always wanted to see Tom Hanks and
Emma Watson come together it's like the
second she came on to the screen with
Harry Potter I was like can't wait
what's the genre I have no idea that's
why this is a reaction video right so we
can discover but there's someone someone
who keeps asking me to watch this you
know for trailers not a comedy or a
horse and then we'll listen if it's like
a drama if it doesn't really listen to
motion I kind of don't really do them
who knows maybe we'll have a blank face
maybe we'll be reacting it's okay it's
the closest female intimacy I've had in
a long time
[Music]
potential dban sir
[Music]
human beings
[Music]
we are our best selves yes the circle
there isn't a problem that we cannot
solve we can cure a disease and we can
in hunger without the hoarding of
knowledge and information it's too much
I just feel like a horrible
[Music]
there's a power to change everything
marelize I get us in trouble
[Music]
because good
[Music]
[Music]
that's uncomfortable oh gosh I got
chills for sure oh gosh man man Tom
Hanks playing like an evil Steve Jobs
that's that's crazy Sully in front of
Emma Watson she's doing an American
accent
yeah that sounds awesome I don't even
think she sounds British right now
that's that's really so cool yeah let's
feel a little opening oh she's
definitely doing an American a way to go
that's not a flawless I feel like the
Brits are better at American accent
Sunday I feel like Brits have way sexier
American accents there do people do yeah
like yeah like ya know they speak proper
yeah yeah [ __ ] America we're seeing a
lot of movies that I think touch on the
themes of Technology really overpowering
the world these days and how there's no
privacy whatsoever a lot of movies are
dealing with this theme this looks to be
one of the more he reversions of that
though because the way the whole
presentation is set up in the world
really embracing it it felt rather
organic it felt like yeah this is how we
do respond to these things in real life
but there really is no privacy
it's it's scary and it feels like that's
how you know that it's happening yeah um
do you watch Black Mirror
I don't watch black men like here that
deals with that kind of stuff a lot that
this is what it reminded me of that a
lot thank you thank you I'll catch up
with every [ __ ] show that everyone's
like the trailers setting it up like Tom
Hanks is a bad guy in his movie and Tom
Hanks is always a good guy even winning
even when he's bad he's still a good
dude do you know
yeah Tom Hanks is like the nicest
[ __ ] fella in the world but I
definitely see him as someone who's
rather villainous here but I like the
kind of villainous role the guy who
really does believe he's doing something
right
I agree I totally agree that's why I
reminded me I'm Inferno because no it
isn't Tom Hanks no I mean the bad guy
Tom Hanks is the bad guy oh no are you
ruining the movie for me yeah they might
keep asking questions you spoil it for
me it looks like Emma Watson's going all
over the world in this cuz then towards
the end of the trailer when it's like
fast pacing through everything you get
footage from like all over the world
here and then there's one spot where
Emma Watson's like river raft is like
underwater oh the one chick who's crying
and like the cell room or something so
are those little I wonder if those
little like that thing she was holding
up I mean it just looked like a camera
I wonder if that's those are everywhere
yeah I think those like drones and stuff
yeah oh that would be crazy it seemed
like to have like a little miniature
drone that you could bring with you
everywhere you go oh my god you know you
could spy on so many people it was
actually kind of cool to have that you
would know every kind of cool to have
that I could finally see you and your
boyfriend going close your windows yes
and I'll send you in a movie yeah
exactly how do you feel about the it's
like there is there's so many pros and
cons to the idea that you can actually
see pretty much everything that goes on
now you think that the show but I think
it's well what if there are terrorists
where the weapons of mass destruction
everyone have something to hide but not
in like not mean in a scale honestly you
know it's like yes great everything in
life scales from one to a hundred
according to technical science rules
something I would like to see another
trailer for this because I want to see
what like the strong emotional grasp is
cuz john boyega's in this and as you all
know John boyega is the man from Star
Wars The Force awakens attack the block
he's the black guy you know he's the
black guy let's just put it that simple
so everyone knows
you know anything about Star Wars well
he's in it he's the first male lead
black actor and that's amazing yeah
which one clearly you don't support
black lives matter matter she supports
it now I'm wondering what the emotional
context of this is gonna be because I
think plots like this are fascinating
where you can like explore the themes of
privacy and all that but yeah there's no
real emotional like story or role going
on then these movies can feel kind of
void to me yeah I totally agree actually
I mean it has to be what I would like to
see though is at least one strong scene
between Tom Hanks and Hamill I feel like
when Emma Watson uncovers whatever the
hell the circle was really up to she's
gonna discover yeah she's gonna come
into a room or Tom Hanks as they already
reveals everything in an evil manner
yeah exactly exactly I hope so I hope
because you know Tom Hanks uneasy right
now
yeah Tom Hanks is poor he hasn't had a
hit in a long time you're like one out
of five people who saw infernal who else
do you know songs are know besides
whoever you went with the scene further
alright guys thanks for tuning in
subscribe today
Jesse Lucas or no is on the suite eats
Channel just hear those words sweet eats
it's more than just healthy baking
recipes it's also sweet eats refers to
their wonderful personalities right
that's a good promotion right it doesn't
that's a great promotional one yeah yeah
raise the ego and people will love that
I don't mind promoting you guys I don't
know why you guys don't invite me on
well that's not fair because I vow to
you Greg okay yeah bring me on I want to
meet your boyfriend yeah I want to punch
me face then all then knowing how strong
he is my like this will bounce off the
wall